come on cap hi everyone its Charlie this
is gonna be part two of my Avengers
endgame Easter eggs video there was so
many the movie was three hours long of
course I had to break it into two videos
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos it's only gonna get crazier we're
even supposed to get a new spider-man
far from home trailer in the next week
or so so don't worry I'll remind
everybody about that at the end of the
video there's a new round of that
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Easter Egg from
the movie on the video obviously very
big spoiler warning for Avengers end
game if you have not seen the movie yet
we'll be talking about specific stuff
including the very end of the film so
picking up where I left off with the
part 1 video there in 2012 still Captain
America is fighting himself the new
footage that they shot was also another
Easter Egg for Thor the dark world
remember when Loki turned into Captain
America just to make fun of Thor when
they were getting ready to escape from
Asgard when they're taking Loki into
custody they take the elevator down
there that funny Hulk joke but they tell
Loki to turn into Steve Rogers Captain
America so as not to draw a suspicion
when they're on the ground floor they
don't want everybody freaking out that
Loki is walking around with them I
already talked about all the Easter eggs
with Loki disappearing about the logic
of what happened to that Loki he created
a new timeline he could come back and
present-day they could serve that as the
basis for the Loki TV series they're
doing during Marvel phase 4 but they're
unsuccessful the test right gets away
they still need to go back in time to
the 1970s because the tesseract was in
that shield facility that Tony Stark's
father and a younger version of Hank Pym
ant-man were both working at the
birthplace of Captain America in New
Jersey when the camera pans up on that
base it's right out of Winter Soldier if
you remember the bunker where they found
Arnim Zola had uploaded himself to the
computers that's the base that they go
back to we get our Stan Lee cameo he
zooms by as a 1970s version of himself
Stan Lee was very active during the
1970s so he's dressed his haircut his
mustache looks exactly like it did
during 1970 the Russos claimed that this
is the last cameo that he filmed before
he passed away so I don't know what
they're gonna do about Stan Lee inside
spider-man
from home they'll probably find some
other way to honor him but when they go
into that shield facility Steve Rogers
name is Roscoe which is actually a
reference to a character Roscoe Simmons
from the Captain America comics that
briefly picked up the mantle of Captain
America during the 1970s Ironman uses
the name Howard Potts and obviously they
run into Hank Pimm's lab which is in
that facility you see a 1970s version of
the ant-man helmet you see a very very
young-looking Michael Douglas just
letting you know that they can do that
pretty easily with these actors at this
point they run it to Yvette Nicole Brown
from community like I said during the
last video she was the other community
cameo during this Captain America
accidentally runs into Peggy Carter
who's talking about an agent Braddock
remember this is the 1970s who is
Captain Britain in the comics I wouldn't
say it's them officially canonizing
Captain Britain to the MCU but it sounds
like if he wasn't the MCU he was alive
and active around the 1970s so he'd be
an old man in present-day iron man goes
down into the bowels of the facility to
look for the tesseract in storage and
runs into his father in the 1970s they
joke about being a dad because remember
iron man is a dad during the film so
they actually have something in common
he basically gives him the exact same
speech saying the things that he wish he
had said at the beginning of Civil War
when they're using the VAR effing
technology he gets the moment with his
father that he never got in real life
they have a cameo from Jarvis on the
agent Carter series I believe that this
is the very first time that an actor
that was a character on a TV series
first now jumped into the movies like
people wonder if TV actors will ever
appear in the movies this is the very
first time that's happened they also
drop an Arnim Zola reference because his
father Howard Stark is looking for Arnim
Zola who hadn't uploaded himself into
the mainframe at that point
speaking of Red Skull related stuff when
Black Widow and Hawkeye go to Vermeer to
get the soul stone she learns from the
very first time during the introduction
that her father's name was ivan she says
she never knew her father because of the
Red Room program that she was inducted
into so this is the first time she's
hearing that jumping over to Morag in
2014 so nebula and war machine go to get
the power stone from Peter quill they
make all kinds of Indiana Jones
references they make fun of Peter quill
because they do the guardians of the
galaxy intro but you're seeing it from
their perspective so you don't hear the
music really loud
so he's just dancing around looking kind
of silly obviously it's the 2014 version
of nebula the interfaces with the one
from present-day
she finds out what's going on alert
stano's they captured that version of
nebula take her Pym particles
reverse-engineer them that's how they
brought all of Danna says 2014 ship his
troops his army and the future version
of nebula back to present day we go to
the events of Thor the dark world there
weren't that many Easter eggs but they
did a brand new scene with Rene Russo as
Thor's mother it was wonderful she
reminds us she was raised by witches
she's the one that taught Loki how to
use magic so she can see right through
what they're trying to do you're from
the future but before they go back Thor
says wait one second and reaches out to
call Mjolnir because it hasn't been
destroyed yet Thor Ragnarok hasn't
happened Frigga jokes sometimes it takes
a second Thor grabs it and says yeah I'm
worthy I'm still worthy and they go back
to present day if you're wondering what
happened to it at the end of the film
Captain America took it back just like
he took the Infinity stones back to the
places that they took them from so Thor
during the events of the dark world got
his hammer back eventually they come
back to present-day iron man makes his
version of the Infinity Gauntlet with a
stark technology which he did during the
comics Hulk wears the Infinity Gauntlet
because he's the only one powerful
enough to wield it at that moment
Hulk also wielded the Infinity Gauntlet
in the Ultimate Comics Ironman wielded
it in the Ultimate Comics as well
there's a lot of different people that
have wielded the Infinity Gauntlet even
spider-man who we see playing hot potato
with it later in the movie nebula picks
the gauntlet up at one point she wore it
during the Infinity Gauntlet saga they
had to get it off of her Captain America
has wielded the Infinity Gauntlet in the
comics strangely enough though he does
not wield it during the movie they snap
everyone back but it's in 2023 five
years in the future from when the
original snap happened so I'll explain
the spider-man twist at the end and the
Captain America twist the Russos already
confirmed an earlier theory that I had
but as they start to fight the 2014
version of Thanos Thor dual wields storm
breaker in Mjolnir during the fight the
hammer is called but it comes to Captain
America he wields it just like he
wielded Thor's hammer in the comics it
was one of the best moments of the film
everyone in my theater screamed out loud
when it looks like all is lost in
Captain America is standing against
Thanos army by himself
you get Falcon on the comms
on your left which is a reference to
Winter Soldier on your left in Doctor
Strange and Wong Portal almost every
single MCU character you've ever seen in
history into the battlefield to help
back him up this is sort of the biggest
version of a splash page that they've
ever done in a scene on screen it's like
the uber version of the airport battle
leaving Captain America to give the
biggest Avengers Assemble you've ever
seen on screen they're between thirty
and forty characters on screen at once
including the original Avengers that
we've seen during the course of the
movie so you have Iron Man Captain
America Thor Hawkeye Hulk Falcon war
machine Scarlet Witch ant-man the wasp
spider-man comes back star-lord
our version of nebula but Gamora from
2014 because older nebula killed the
younger version of nebula remember you
can't change the past so even though she
kills her it's not gonna wink
older nebula out of existence Drax
rocket group comes back as teenage Groot
mantis dr. strange Wong of course black
panther Ikoyi a black panther is
actually the first person to walk
through the portal after Sam Falcon says
on your left which I thought was kind of
weird I thought it would have been nicer
if he came out first but I guess they
wanted Black Panther to come back first
just because he was such a huge
character for everyone during 2018
Bucky Valkyrie Captain Marvel comes back
she even fights with danos for a brief
period she's actually so strong that
she's almost able to solo the gauntlet
by herself till tano's uses the power
stone to punch her a couple miles away
Shuri mbaku
Pepper Potts comes back in her rescue
dawn armor full on armor she army and go
back to back fighting with each other
during the film Korg comes back a whole
bunch of other sorcerers from Doctor
Strange and the other sanctums around
the planet come to help out double
Condon army even Howard the Duck comes
back cracklin in all the Ravagers that
are still alive come back because it's
the 2014 version of Thanos too though
all of the Black Order come back
epidemic
Corvus glaive Proxima midnight co
obsidian the outriders the Chitauri in a
whole bunch of other larger creatures
that we did not see during infinity war
a lot of people also asking about the
iron Patriot armor too like wait a
minute
wasn't this Rody's armor a long time ago
they used this briefly what's the deal
with this I
they just wanted to have more Iron Man
armors on screen during this moment they
have an a force moment during the film
if you're not familiar with a force
they're just a team of women that are
basically like another Avengers side
team in the comics so they have like a
giant team up with Captain Marvel when
she's facing down Thanos I think that
was just them winking at the idea of a
force I don't know if they're ever gonna
do an a force movie but they haven't
announced plans or anything like that
when spider-man reunites with Ironman
Ironman hugs him on the spot he says aw
this is nice which is a nice callback to
Spider Man far from home when he thought
that he was hugging him and he's like no
we're not there yet kid when iron man
dies he also sort of has the reverse
moment that Iron Man had with him during
infinity war when Spider Man died
Spider Man also activates instant kill
mode when he gets dogpile by a bunch of
outriders activate instant kill mode
black panther remembers hawk eyes named
Clint so he apparently does care this
time when Thanos thinks that he's won
the day he tries to snap the start tech
gauntlet but finds that Iron Man has
joined all the Infinity stones - his
gauntlet he says I am inevitable then
Iron Man goes out on his very famous
line from the end of Iron Man 1 I am
Iron Man and snaps all of tamás's forces
out of existence he did not snap Gamora
from 2014 out of existence that's why
Peter quill is looking at a Gamora
display at the end of the film because
he wants to go find her because she
turned against Thanos so she's kind of a
good person now but she's not good like
the original version of Gamora that we
knew during Iron Man's funeral they have
pretty much all the bigger Avengers
characters their families and side
characters with them they say goodbye to
him and they sort of eulogize him with
that original arc reactor proof that
Tony Stark does have a heart remember
the time travel platform design was
actually made to look like this when
they all had their hands in the middle
just another way to visually represent
the Iron Man character was to the MC
within the context of the story but also
how important that original Iron Man
film was for building Marvel Studios and
everything that came after the kid from
Iron Man 3 comes back but he's a
teenager now he's way older because it's
been a long time since that movie
happened and on top of that there was a
five-year time jump when happy sits down
with his daughter she says I want a
cheeseburger he almost starts crying on
the spot and says you know what your
father
like cheeseburgers which is a reference
to the original Iron Man movie when he
first escaped the cave came back and
said what do you want to do first I want
to get a cheeseburger and I want to call
press conference Thor officially gives
leadership of Asgard to Valkyrie calling
her Queen so we'll see how they address
that in future movies but Thor
officially joins the guardians of the
galaxy calling it as guardians of the
galaxy which they actually did in the
comics briefly recently like I said
Peter quill is planning on going to find
Gamora during that that'll probably be
the events of guardians of the galaxy
vol 3
I don't know obviously what other stuff
Thor's gonna be doing during that movie
but Adam warlock is also going to be a
big character and Thor's one of the most
powerful people in the MCU so they'll
just have somebody who's powerful enough
to counter Adam warlock the Russos also
confirm my theory about spider-man far
from home in the five-year time jump so
in the trailers that we've seen so far
all of his core classmates basically the
debate team are together they're the
same age the idea is is that all of them
got snapped when they're brought back
through the same age which explains how
they're all the same age during
spider-man far from home and it seems
like no time has passed even though it's
five years later but there are some of
these classmates probably the ones that
we've never seen on screen before who
are five years older enter now in
college or out having jobs so unless the
Russos are bold-faced lying to us again
then spider-man far from home takes
place during 2023 after the events of
endgame which we kind of thought before
we knew it would take place after
in-game but we didn't know about the
five-year time jump then they have the
Captain America scene where he has to
take all the Infinity stones back to
where they stole them from a Mjolnir
back to Thor the dark world he and Bucky
have a conversation saying don't do
anything stupid till I get back Steve
says and Bucky says how can I you're
taking all the stupid with you that's
the exact same conversation they had way
back in the 1940s when Bucky went off to
serve in World War two when they tried
to bring him back though it doesn't work
he shows up on a bench as old man cap so
there are a lot of questions about the
logic of this situation because very
clearly he lived out his life with Peggy
Carter in the past the Russos confirm my
original theory that the movie is
sticking to its time-travel logic so
what happened is is because you can't
change anything in the past whenever you
do something in the past that's
different you just create an alternate
timeline so what happened is is Captain
goes back to have that dance that he
promised to Peggy Carter save that dance
for me their song plays over the credits
you know he says to Falcon you know what
I don't think I'm gonna tell you about
that girl because he has the wedding
ring on his finger
clearly Peggy Carter was his wife but he
gives Falcon the shield and says try it
on
Falcon probably won't debut as the next
Captain America till the next Avengers
movie so it could be four years before
we see that but they'll probably give us
more explainers about that later this
summer the way the Captain America winds
up on this bench / the Russos confirming
my theory is is that because Captain
America was changing the timeline and
creating a new one when he stayed with
Peggy in the past in the 1940s what
happened is is that he had to come back
later to our own timeline which means
that he probably saved some Pym
particles or got some along the way
and saved the time-travel suit so that's
how he wound up coming back then just
arrange to walk up and sit on this bench
before this moment happened so it wasn't
him just directly coming back to this
moment it was him coming back to some
other earlier point in time and they
just sort of kind of trotting up and
sitting on the bench knowing that this
would all be happening in the next
couple of minutes but the Russos D
confirmed that he lived out his life
with Peggy Carter here that's an
alternate timeline that's not our own
timeline very interesting they also said
that they couldn't answer any more
details about exactly what year he went
back to because they might cover that
story in another Disney Plus streaming
show or in another movie so there will
be more Chris Evans Captain America
stuff in the MCU at some point it just
might happen in a very roundabout way
there's no traditional mid-credits scene
but at the end there's sort of like a
post-credits end credits moment where
you hear Ironman hammering I believe
it's actually six times I've listened to
it a couple times now and I used to
think it was three but it's six times on
metal it's just the sound of him
hammering the Iron Man armor mark 1 in
the cave in that original Iron Man film
which is just sort of callback to the
beginning of all this stuff so if you
spotted any other Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video just post
them below in the comments and like I
said there's a new spider-man far from
home trailer that's gonna drop in the
next week of course I'll do a video for
it as soon as they post it
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video on you for
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here for all my Avengers in-game Easter
eggs part 1 video and
here for my brand-new Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 4 trailer video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]